So those women for me, they are my heroes,
because they are innovators, they are solution makers,
they are changing the little of the resources
into the big for the community.
So those are my people.
So we use our indigenous people's traditional knowledge
to get better resilience to what we need to survive.
Our knowledge is not only for our communities.
It's to share with each and others who are living with us.
And indigenous peoples around the world
are saving 80 percent of the world's biodiversity.
That's the scientists who say that.
Indigenous peoples in the Amazon,
you can find the most diverse ecosystem, better than the national park.
The indigenous peoples from the Pacific,
the grandma and the grandpa,
they know where to get food after the hurricane hits them.
So the knowledge that our peoples know
is helping us to survive and helping other peoples also to survive
the climate change impact.
The world is losing.
We lost already 60 percent of the species,
and it's increasing every day.
So one day, I took a scientist to my community.
I said, you are giving the good weather information through the TV and radio,
but how about coming to my people?
And then they come,
they sit around,
and suddenly, as we are nomadic, we just start packing our stuff,
and then they say, like, "Are we moving?"
I'm like, "No, we are not moving. It's going to rain."
And they're like, "Oh, there's no cloud. How do you know it's going to rain?"
We're like, "Yeah, it's going to rain." We pack our stuff.
Suddenly, heavy rain starts coming,
and we are seeing the scientist running around, hiding under trees
and protecting their stuff.
We already packed ours.
(Laughter)
After the end of the rain, the serious discussion starts.
They say, "How do you know that it's going to rain?"
We say, "Well, the old woman observed the insects
taking the eggs inside their homes,
and while the insect cannot talk or watch TV,
they know how to predict to protect their generations,
how to protect their food.
So for us it's the sign that it's going to rain
in at maximum a couple of hours."
And then they say,
well, we do have knowledge,
but we do not combine ecological knowledge and weather knowledge all together.
So that's how I started working
with meteorological scientists and my communities
to give better information to get peoples adapted to climate change.
I think, if we put together all the knowledge systems that we have --
science, technology,
traditional knowledge --
we can give the best of us to protect our peoples,
to protect our planet,
to restore the ecosystem that we are losing.
I did that in another way, also.
I used a tool that I really love a lot.
It's called a 3D participatory mapping:
participatory, because it can bring women, men,
youth, elders,
all the intergenerational peoples.
Then they use science-based knowledge,
and the community comes together, they build this map,
they figure out all the knowledge that we have
about where is our sacred forest, where is our water point,
where is our corridor,
where is the place that we move during each season.
And these tools are amazing, because it's building capacity of women,
because in our communities
women and men cannot sit together.
Men talk always, women just sitting there,
but in the back.
They are not there to take any decision.
So after the men figure out all the knowledge,
we say, well, you call the women, "Come and have a look."
They say, "Yes, sure,"
because they've already done the first work.
(Laughter)
When the women come,
and they look at the map, they're like, "Mm, no."
(Laughter)
"This is wrong.
Here's where I collect the medicine. Here's where I collect the food.
Here's where I collect --"
So we changed the knowledge in the map,
and we called the men.
Well, they think about what women say.
All of them shaking their heads.
"They are right. They are right.
They are right."
So that's how we build the capacity of the women
in giving them a voice
in this 3D participatory mapping,
so women get the detailed knowledge
that can help the community to adapt.
And man have the bigger picture knowledge.
So when we put it together,
this map helps them to discuss
but to mitigate the conflict between the communities
to access the resources,
to share better these resources,
to restore it
and to manage it for the long term.
Our knowledge is very useful.
Indigenous peoples' knowledge
are very crucial for our planet.
It's crucial for all the peoples.
Science knowledge was discovered 200 years ago,
technology 100 years ago,
but indigenous peoples' knowledge, it's thousands of years ago.
So why we cannot put all of these together,
combine those three knowledges
and give the better resilience
to the peoples who are getting the impact of climate change?
And now it's not only the developing countries.
It's the developed countries also.
We saw the hurricane. We saw the flood around all the places.
We saw the fire, even here in California.
So we need all this knowledge to come together.
We need the people in the center.
And we need the decision makers to change,
scientists tell them,
and we tell them,
and we do have this knowledge.
We have 10 years to change it.
Ten years is nothing,
so we need to act all together
and we need to act right now.
Thank you.
(Applause)